it's that time of the month again the
6-3 PlayStation Plus games for December
2016 have been announced to PlayStation
4 2 + 3 3 + 2 for the Vita as well
we have turn-based stealth an action RPG
a few side scrollers and a classic spare
shoot of this month which should tell
you over the Christmas period and into
2017 I want to record things this month
isn't great but hopefully there's
something for everyone
let's start with the offerings on ps4
first up is the Steam hit invisible ink
boasting a user rating of 9 out of 10
this game is a turn-based tactical
stealth game playing in a similar vent
XCOM but with more of a focus on covert
strategy rather than all-out war the
brilliance of this game comes in the
shape of randomized enemy locations and
behaviors meaning every single
playthrough will be different another
cool little mechanic is the time walk
function which acts like the sons of
time in Prince of Persia and allows the
player to time travel back to the
previous turn all in all these game
types are kinda like Marmite Evie you
love them or you just don't care please
let me know what you think below next up
on ps4 is stories the paths of destinies
an action RPG boasting a Metacritic
score of 73 percent stories has a rather
basic gameplay style similar to every
action RPG that springs to manage but
the art style and storytelling are what
sets this game apart as the title
suggests your journey is narrated as if
it was a storybook once the game is
complete which is around 25 levels the
player can flip back through the book
and make different choices to uncover
more of the story which may have been
missed during the first playthrough
there are 24 endings which when unlocked
build a final definitive ending for you
to enjoy intrigue please let us know
what you think below before we move on
to the ps3 please do me a huge favor and
click the sub button as we really need
your support to help our channel grow
right onto the ps3 and first up is hyper
void which is a classic space shooter
with a futuristic neon art style the
sensation of speed is rather impressive
and the control scheme feels perfect for
this type of game with 29 levels and an
insane difficulty increase this one may
frustrate the casual gamer
what do you think next up is tiny trucks
and in this slightly formal this is the
one that I'll be picking up if you ever
had a Super Nintendo you'll know the
classic game cannon fodder
well tiny truth is the closest modern
representation of that game available
sadly it feels like a mobile game and
the controls can be frustrating at times
but with 30 levels and a bit of
nostalgia this could be one for you now
time for the Vita and first up is color
Guardians after the world has been
deprived of all color your job is to
bring back vibrance by picking up paint
balls fighting like Sonic the Hedgehog
cross with Raymond this one is a
reactive side scroller which is
massively repetitive with a Metacritic
score of 62 out of 100 this is super
repetitive oh did I say this game is
quite repetitive well it is
and finally vvvvvv well I think that's
how you say or it could be it's the last
offering for December 2016 and resembles
games from the 1980s it plays like Super
Meat Boy without the nuances the world
is chaotic and you will die numerous
times until you figure out the right
thing to do GamesRadar give this the
most favorable score of 8 out of 10 so
what are you playing this month let us
know below I'm underwhelmed by this
month offerings but before you know it
January's game 2 over here I'm Adam from
PlayStation grenade and if you're new
round these parts please check out some
of our other content thanks for your
time please press subscribe maybe even
liked it as well see you next time